federal prosecutors say that a man who
planned to attack the White House with
explosives and an anti-tank rocket is
under arrest
his name is hashira jalal tie ab he's
charged with attempting to damage or
destroy a building owned by the US using
fire or an explosive the 21 year old
georgia man allegedly planned to carry
out a carry out rather a terror attack
today
Jeffrey gazes at FBI headquarters in
Washington with new details of this
investigation
Jeff good morning good morning according
to the FBI the suspect was radicalized
and intent on carrying out an attack
here in Washington that included blowing
the hole in the White House but last
March the FBI got a tip that allowed
them to infiltrate and disrupt the
suspects plot according to an FBI
affidavit initially the suspect wanted
to travel overseas to areas controlled
by Isis allegedly told a confidential
FBI source in October that he planned to
sell his car to fund his travel but he
didn't have a passport so those plans
change and he set his sights on the US
investigators say he decided he wanted
to conduct an attack in the United
States to have allegedly told an
undercover FBI agent in December that he
wanted to attack the Washington Monument
the White House the Lincoln Memorial and
a specific synagogue he allegedly wanted
to use firearms and anti-tank rocket and
backpacks with explosives
it was arrested yesterday in Buford
Georgia and FBI agents and other law
enforcement agencies were seen going in
and out of his home in [ __ ] Georgia
yesterday now a woman who says that she
knows two halves family says that they
were quiet she didn't see any red flags
but someone did and notified the FBI
investigators believe that he was acting
alone Nora
what a story Jeff thank you